used
only after the chancellor has addressed
this host
is rather different to what we have
apparently experienced this year
that is the briefing to the media
of details of the budget statement to be
published before the statement is
delivered
as mr speaker has said
and all ministers know
important policy announcements should be
made first to parliament
um
given there shouldn't be shouts of
resign over there that's not what we're
talking about we're just talking
about courtesy to this house
given my responsibilities to the house
with regard to the budget i must put on
record my support for mr speaker's
stance on this issue and express a firm
hope
which i believe is felt on all sides of
the house
that we do not find ourselves in this
position again at future budgets
but chancellor we are all very much
looking forward to hearing the remainder
of your announcement which you're about
to make to us
i would like to know
oh no you haven't the chancellor has
still to give us the important parts of
his budget
i
remind honorable members that copies of
the budget resolutions will be available
from the vote office and members lobby
after the chancellor's statement and of
course online i also remind honourable
members
we will have good behavior over this
next hour or so
interventions are not taken during the
chancellor's statement nor indeed during
the republic well eleanor lang who is
from the conservative
side backing up lindsey hoyle of course
is labour
attacking the chancellor for the way in
which the contents of the budget have
been leaked in advance now
we will get
the chancellor's budget statement rishi
sunak at the dispatch box
madam deputy speaker i've heard your
words and those of uh mr speaker i have
the greatest respect for you both and i
want to assure you that i have listened
very carefully to what you have said
and may i also madam deputy speaker send
my best wishes to the leader of the
opposition and i know the whole house
will join me in doing that and now with
your permission madam deputy speaker let
me turn to today's budget
madam deputy speaker
employment is up
investment
is growing public services are improving
the public finances are stabilizing and
wages are rising
[Music]
[Applause]
today's budget delivers a stronger
economy for the british people stronger
growth with the uk recovering faster
than our major competitors
stronger public finances with our debt
under control stronger employment with
fewer people out of work and more people
in work
growth up
jobs up and debt down let there be no
doubt our plan is working
[Music]
madam deputy speaker
this budget is about what this
government is about investment in a more
innovative high-skilled economy because
that is the only sustainable path to
individual prosperity
world-class public services because
these are the common goods from which we
all benefit backing business because our
future cannot be built by government
alone but must come from the imagination
and drive of our entrepreneurs
help for working families with the cost
of living because we will always give
people the support they need and the
tools to build a better life for
themselves
and
leveling up
because for too long
far too long the location of your birth
has determined too much of your future
because the awesome power of opportunity
shouldn't be available only to a wealthy
few but be the birthright of every
and child united kingdom
madam deputy speaker
today's budget does not draw a line
under covid we have challenging months
ahead and let me encourage everyone
eligible to get their booster jabs as
soon as possible
but today's budget does begin the work
of preparing for a new economy postcovid
the prime minister's economy of higher
wages higher skills and rising
productivity of strong public services
vibrant communities and safer streets an
economy fit for a new age of optimism
where the only limit to our potential is
the effort we are prepared to put in and
the sacrifices we are prepared to make
that is the stronger economy of the
future and this budget is the foundation
madam deputy speaker
the house will recognize the challenging
backdrop of rising inflation
let me begin by carefully explaining
what is happening in our economy and why
inflation in september was 3.1
and is likely to rise further
with the obr expecting cpi to average
four percent over the next year
the majority of this rise in inflation
can be explained by two global forces
first as economies around the world
reopen demand for goods has increased
more quickly than supply chains can be
having been shut down for almost a year
it takes time for factories to scale up
production for container ships to move
goods to where demand is for businesses
to hire the people they need
and second global demand for energy has
surged at a time when supplies have
already been disrupted putting a strain
on prices
in the year to september the global
wholesale price of oil coal and gas
combined has more than doubled
the pressures caused by supply chains
and energy prices will take months to
ease
it would be irresponsible for anyone to
pretend that we can solve this overnight
i'm in regular communication with
finance ministers around the world and
it's clear these are shared global
problems
neither unique to the uk
nor possible for us to address on our
own
but where the government can ease these
pressures
we will act to address the driver
shortage the transport secretary is
introducing temporary visas tackling
testing backlogs changing cabotage
requirements and is today announcing new
funding to improve lorry park facilities
[Applause]
we've
we've already suspended the hgv levy
until august and i can do more today
extending it for a further year until
2023 and freezing vehicle excise duty
for heavy goods vehicles
to help with the cost of living we've
introduced a new half a billion pound
household support fund and today's
budget will support working families
further and in terms of our fiscal
policy
we are going to meet our commitments on
public services and capital investment
but we are going to do so keeping in
mind the need to control inflation and
finally i have written to the governor
of the bank of england today to reaffirm
their remit to achieve low and stable
inflation
and people should be reassured they have
a strong track record in doing so
i understand people are concerned about
global inflation
but they have a government here at home
ready and willing to act
and madam deputy speaker
in a period of global uncertainty
you need to work hard to maintain a
strong economy and be responsible with
the public finances and that is what we
are doing
i'm grateful to the obr for their work
and i'm pleased to say
they now expect our recovery to be
quicker
thanks to this government's actions they
forecast the economy to return to its
pre-covered level at the turn of the
year earlier than they thought in march
growth this year is revised up from four
to six and a half percent
obr then expect the economy to grow by
six percent in 2022 and 2.1 1.3 and 1.6
over the next three years
in july last year at the height of the
pandemic unemployment was expected to
peak at 12 percent
today the obr expect unemployment to
peak at just 5.2 percent
that means over two million fewer people
out of work than previously feared
and wages are rising compared to
february 2020 they have grown in real
terms by almost three and a half percent
and i can confirm for the house the
obr's forecast for business investment
has been revised up over the next five
years
and because of the actions
we took to support our economy we have
been more successful than previously
feared in preventing the long-term
economic damage of covid
the obr have today
revised down their scarring assumption
from three percent to two percent
[Music]
in the depths of the worst economic
crisis on record we set out a plan for
jobs a plan that was backed by business
groups and trade bodies a plan that has
helped millions of people and saved
millions of jobs a plan that the obr
have today described as remarkably
successful madam deputy speaker today's
forecast confirmed beyond doubt our plan
for jobs is working
[Music]
[Applause]
and madam deputy speaker
disruption in the global economy
highlights the importance of strong
public finances
coronavirus left us with borrowing
higher than at any time since the second
world war
as the prime minister reminded us in his
conference speech
higher borrowing today is just higher
interest rates and even higher taxes
tomorrow so we need to strengthen our
public finances so that when the next
crisis comes we have the fiscal space to
act
today i am publishing a new charter for
budget
responsibility the charter sets out two
fiscal rules which will keep this
government on the path of discipline and
responsibility
first
underlying public sector net debt
excluding the impact of the bank of
england
must as a percentage of gdp be falling
second
in normal times the state should only
borrow to invest in our future growth
and prosperity everyday spending must be
paid through taxation
both rules must be met by the third year
of every forecast period giving us the
flexibility to respond to crises while
credibly keeping our public finances
under control these rules are
supplemented by targets to spend up to
three percent of gdp on capital
investment and keep welfare spending on
a sustainable path
madam deputy speaker
the house will be asked to vote on our
charter giving members a simple choice
to abandon our fiscal anchor and leave
our economy adrift with reckless
unfunded pledges
or to vote for what we on this side of
the house no is the right course
sound public finances and a stronger
economy for the british people
madam deputy speaker
important as the charter is
our credibility comes as much from what
we do
as what we say
so i'm pleased to tell the house
that because our plan is delivering a
stronger economy and because we've taken
tough but responsible decisions on
public finances
the obr report today
that all our fiscal rules have been met
[Music]
underlying debt is forecast to be 85.2
percent of gdp this year then 85.4 of
gdp in 2223
before peaking at 85.7 percent in 2324
it then falls in the final three years
of the forecast from 85.1 to 83.3
percent
borrowing as a percentage of gdp is
forecast to fall in every single year
from 7.9 this year to 3.3 next then 2.4
1.7 1.7 and 1.5 in the following years
borrowing down
debt
down
proving once again it is the
conservatives and only the conservatives
who could be trusted with taxpayers
money
[Applause]
madam deputy speaker
i have made four fiscal judgments in
this budget first we will meet our
fiscal rules with a margin to protect
ourselves against economic risks
that is the responsible decision at a
time of increasing global economic
uncertainty when our public finances are
twice as sensitive to changes in
interest rates as they were before the
pandemic and six times as sensitive as
they were before the financial crisis
just a one percentage point in inflation
and interest rates would cost us around
23 billion pounds
my second judgment today is to continue
supporting working families
third
as well as helping people at home our
improving fiscal situation
means we will meet our obligations to
the world's poorest
i told the house then we met our fiscal
test we would return to spending 0.7
percent of our national income on
overseas aid
some people said this was a trick or a
device
i told this house it was no such thing
and based on the tests i set out today's
forecast show that we are in fact
scheduled to return to 0.7 in 2425
before the end of this parliament
[Music]
and madam deputy speaker
my fourth my fourth fiscal judgment is
this
today's budget
increases total departmental spending
over this parliament by a hundred and
fifty billion pounds that's the largest
increase this century with spending
growing by three point eight percent a
year in real terms
as a result of this spending review
and contrary to speculation
there will be a real terms rise in
overall spending for every single
department
and public sector net investment as a
share of gdp will be at the highest
sustained level for nearly half a
century
if anybody still doubts it today's
budget confirms the conservatives are
the real party of public services
[Music]
madam madam deputy speaker
deputy speaker our stronger economy
lays the foundation for everything we
want to achieve in today's budget
world-class public services and more
investment in our future growth
before i turn to the details i'd like to
thank my right honourable friend the
chief secretary
completing the spending review in such
challenging circumstances was a tall
order and thankfully we had just the man
for the job
madam deputy speaker at the start of
this parliament resource spending on
health care was a 133 billion pounds
today's spending review confirms that by
the end of this parliament it will
increase by 44 billion pounds to over
177 billion and the extra revenue we're
forecast to raise from the health and
social care levy is going direct to the
nhs and social care as promised
the health capital budget will be the
largest since 2010 record investment in
health r d including better newborn
screening as campaigned for by the
member for the cities of london and
westminster
40 new hospitals 70 hospital upgrades
more operating theaters to tackle the
backlog and a hundred community
diagnostic centers
all staffed by a bigger better trained
workforce with 50 000 more nurses and 50
million more primary care appointments
as well as funding to deliver the prime
minister's historic reforms to social
care
we're providing local government with
new grant funding over the next three
years of 4.8 billion pounds the largest
increase in core funding for over a
decade
and we're investing more in housing and
home ownership too with a multi-year
housing settlement totaling nearly 24
billion pounds eleven and a half billion
to build up to their 180 000 new
affordable homes the largest cash
investment in a decade 20 larger than
the previous program
and we're investing an extra 1.8 billion
pounds enough to bring 1500 hectares of
brownfield land into use meet our
commitment to invest 10 billion pounds
in new hampshire and unlock a million
new homes
we're also confirming five billion
pounds to remove unsafe cladding from
the highest gris buildings
partly funded by the residential
property developers tax which i can
confirm
will be levied on developers with
profits over 25 million pounds at a rate
of four percent
and we've also reduced rough sleeping by
over a third but we will go further with
640 million pounds a year for rough
sleeping and homelessness an 85
increase in funding compared to 2019.
madam deputy speaker
today's budget funds our ambition to
recruit 20 000 new police officers
provides an extra 2.2 billion pounds for
courts prisons and probation services
including half a billion pounds to
reduce the court's backlog
pays for programs to tackle neighborhood
crime reoffending county lines violence
against women and girls victim services
and improved responses to rape cases
and over the next three years commits
3.8 billion pounds to the largest prison
building program in a generation
madam deputy speaker
all governments should aspire to provide
greater life chances for future
generations
but few governments can match our
ambition
so let me now turn to what this budget
does to support children
the evidence is compelling that the
first thousand and one days of a child's
life are the most important
my right honourable friend my right
honourable friend the member for south
northamptonshire has recognized this
with her inspirational report
[Applause]
and we are responding today with 300
million pounds for a start for life
offer for families high quality
parenting programs tailored services to
help with perinatal mental health and
i'm pleased to tell the member for
congress on funding to create a network
of family hubs around the country too
to improve the quality of child care
we're going to pray providers more with
today's spending review providing an
extra 170 million pounds by 24 25. we're
confirming 150 million pounds to support
training and development for the entire
early years workforce to help up to 300
000 more families facing multiple needs
we're investing an extra 200 million
pounds in the supporting families
program and we will provide over 200
million pounds a year to continue the
holiday activity and food program
today's spending review also
delivers our commitment to schools
with an extra 4.7 billion pounds by 2425
which combined with the ambitious plans
we announced that the spending review of
2019 will restore per pupil funding to
2010 levels in real terms
equivalent equivalent to a cash increase
for every pupil of more than one
thousand 500 pounds
and for children with special
educational needs and disabilities
we are more than tripling the amount we
invest to create 30 000 new school
places
and we know
that the pandemic consort caused
significant disruption to children's
learning we've already announced 3.1
billion pounds to help education
recovery today
as promised by the prime minister and
the education secretary we will go
further with just under two billion
pounds of new funding to help schools
and colleges bringing this government's
total support for education recovery to
almost five billion pounds
madam deputy speaker
as we level up public services we are
also leveling up communities restoring
the pride people feel in the places they
call home
to do that we're providing 560 million
pounds for youth services enough to fund
up to 300 youth clubs across the country
over 200 million pounds to build or
transform 8 000 state-of-the-art
community football pitches across the uk
funding to turn over a hundred areas of
derelict land into new pocket parks and
i'm allocating the first round of bids
from the leveling up fund
1.7 billion pounds to invest in the
infrastructure of everyday life in over
a hundred local areas
with 170 million in scotland 120 million
in wales and 50 million in northern
ireland more than their barnet shares
this will benefit the whole united
kingdom
we are backing projects in aberdeen
berry
burnley lewis kluid south and not one
not two but three successful projects
for the great city of stoke-on-trent
[Applause]
but that's but that's not all
we're also going to fund projects in
ashton underline
south leicester
sunderland
doncaster and west leeds
speaker
we are so committed to levelling up we
are even leveling up the opposition
front bench
[Applause]
madam deputy speaker leveling up is also
about protecting our unique culture and
heritage the british museum tate
liverpool the york railway museum we're
investing 800 and million pounds to
protect museums galleries libraries and
local culture
and thanks to the culture secretary over
a hundred regional museums and libraries
will be renovated restored and revived
and
she secured up to two million pounds to
start work on a new beatles attraction
on the liverpool waterfront
we're also going to review our museum
freedoms and
make our creative tax reliefs more
generous
on current plans the tax relief for
museums and galleries is due to end in
march next year just as exhibitions are
starting to tour again so i've decided
to extend it for two years to march 2024
and to support theaters orchestras
museums and galleries to recover from
covid the tax reliefs for all those
sectors from today until april 2023 will
be doubles and they won't return to the
normal rate until april 2024 that's a
tax relief for culture worth almost a
quarter of a billion pounds
and madam deputy speaker this is a
budget for the whole united kingdom
through the barnet formula today's
decisions increase scottish government
funding in each year by an average of
4.6 billion pounds
welsh government funding by 2.5 billion
pounds and 1.6 billion pounds for the
northern ireland executive
this delivers
this delivers in real terms
the largest block grants for the
devolved administration since the
devolution settlements of 1998
the whole of the united kingdom will
benefit from the uk shared prosperity
fund and over time we will ramp up
funding so that total domestic uk-wide
funding will match eu receipts averaging
around 1.5 billion pounds a year
and we will fund projects across the uk
including funding for the extreme e-race
in scotland the 22 hebrides x-pre
accelerating funding for the cardiff
city region deal in wales and funding in
northern ireland for community cohesion
and whilst today demonstrates the
indisputable fiscal benefit of being
part of the united kingdom
this is
this is
and always will be secondary to the
simple truth that we are bound together
by more than transactional benefit it is
our collective history our culture and
our security we are and always will be
one family one united kingdom
[Applause]
madam deputy speaker
whilst today's budget delivers
historically high levels of public
spending its success
will be measured not by the billions we
spend
but by the outcomes we achieve and the
difference we make to people's lives
the budgets are set the plans are in
place the task is clear now we must
deliver because this isn't the
government's money it's taxpayers money
madam deputy speaker
our stronger economy allows us to fund
world-class public services the people's
priority
but over the long term the only way to
pay for higher spending is economic
growth
and if we want to see higher growth
we've got to tackle the problem that's
been holding back this country for far
too long our uneven economic geography
as we come out of the worst economic
shock we've ever seen we've got a choice
to retrench or to invest
this government chooses to invest
to invest in our economic infrastructure
to invest in innovation to invest in
skills to invest in a plan for growth
that builds a stronger economy for the
future that's what this budget is about
and that's what this government is about
madam deputy speaker infrastructure
connects our country drives productivity
and levels up
that's why our national infrastructure
strategy invests in economic
infrastructure like roads railways
broadband and mobile over 130 billion
pounds
to connect our towns and cities we're
investing 21 billion pounds on roads and
46 billion pounds on railways
our integrated rail plan will be
published soon dramatically improving
journey times between our towns and
cities and today
we're providing 5.7 billion pounds for
london-style transport settlements in
greater manchester the liverpool city
region the teas valley south yorkshire
west yorkshire west midlands and the
west of england
and we're helping local transport
everywhere with 2.6 billion pounds for a
long-term pipeline of over 50 local
roads upgrades over 5 billion pounds for
local roads maintenance enough to fill a
million more potholes a year
and funding for buses cycling and
walking totaling more than five billion
pounds the prime minister promised an
infrastructure revolution this budget
delivers an infrastructure revolution
madam deputy speaker
investment in our infrastructure is just
the first step
we need to do what the people of this
country have always done
invent discover and create the ideas and
technologies that will change the world
so we will also invest more in
innovation
the uk is already a world leader with
less than one percent of the world's
population we have four of the world's
top 20 universities 14
of the world's most impactful research
and the second most low noble laureates
we want to go further
i can confirm we will maintain our
target to increase r d investment to 22
billion pounds but in order to get there
and deliver on our other priorities
we'll reach the target in 2627
spending by the end of this parliament
20 billion pounds a year on r d
that's a cash increase of 50 percent the
fastest increase ever and i can confirm
for the house that this 20 billion
pounds is in addition to the cost of our
r d tax relief
combined with those tax reliefs total
public investment in r d is increasing
from 0.7 of gdp in 2018 to 1.1
of gdp by the end of the parliament
how does 1.1 compare internationally
well
the latest available data shows an oecd
average of just 0.7
germany investing 0.9 france 1
and the united states just 0.7
this unprecedented funding will increase
core science funding to 5.9 billion
pounds per year by 2425
a cash increase of 37
meet the full cost of associating with
horizon europe establish the new
advanced research and invention agency
with 800 million pounds by 25 26 and
strengthen our focus on late stage
innovation increasing innovate uk's
annual core budget to a billion pounds
double what it was at the start of this
parliament
madam deputy speaker there's more to
becoming
a science superpower than just what the
government spends on r d
our ambitious net zero strategy is also
an innovation strategy investing 30
billion pounds to create the new green
industries of the future we've just
issued our second green bond making us
the third largest issuer of sovereign
green bonds anywhere in the world london
last week was named the best place in
the world for green finance and on
monday the new uk infrastructure bank
announced its first ever investment 107
million pounds to support offshore wind
in t side
and to build on this work one week today
i'll be hosting global finance ministers
and businesses at cop26
and madam deputy speaker innovation
comes from the imagination drive and
risk-taking of business
that's why we've launched help to grow
for turbocharged sme productivity
started a new co-investment venture
capital fund future fund breakthrough
it's why i'm announcing today we will
consult on further changes to the
regulatory charge cap for pension
schemes unlocking institutional
investment whilst protecting savers it's
why we're introducing a new 1.4 billion
pound global britain investment fund
supporting transformative economic
activity and our world leading sectors
like life sciences and it's why today's
budget increases the british business
banks regional financing programs to 1.6
billion pounds expanding their coverage
and helping innovative businesses get
access to the finance they need across
the whole united kingdom
[Music]
madam deputy speaker a third of our
science noble laureates have been
immigrants half of our fastest growing
companies have a foreign-born founder so
an economy built on innovation must be
open and attractive to the best and
brightest minds
thanks to our brilliant home secretary
today's budget confirms the eligibility
criteria for our new scale-up visa
making it quicker and easier for the
fast-growing businesses to bring in
highly skilled individuals and the trade
secretaries new global talent network
launching initially in the bay area
boston and bangalore will identify
attract and relocate the best global
talent in science and tech sectors all
part of our plan to make our visa system
for international talent the most
competitive in the world
[Music]
madam deputy speaker
if we want greater private sector
innovation we need to make our research
and development tax reliefs fit for
purpose
the latest figures show the uk has the
second highest spending on r d tax
relief in the oecd
yet it's not working as well as it
should
uk business investment in r d is less
than half the oecd average
we've reviewed the release and
identified two issues we are solving
today
first the reliefs need to reflect how
businesses conduct research in the
modern world
so as many companies have called for i'm
expanding the scope of the release to
include cloud computing and data costs
the second problem is this
companies claimed uk tax relief on 48
billion pounds of r d spending
yet uk business investment was around
half of that at just 26 billion pounds
we are subsidizing billions of pounds of
r d that isn't even happening here in
the united kingdom
that's unfair on british taxpayers and
it puts us out of step with places like
australia canada hong kong singapore
switzerland and the usa who have all
focused their r d tax relief on domestic
activity
so from april 2023 we are going to do
the same and incentivize greater
investment here at home
so madam deputy speaker 22 billion pound
investment in r d the net zero strategy
the future fund help to grow more
regional finance unlocking institutional
capital a more competitive visa system
and a modernized r d tax credits regime
enough action to prove the hypothesis we
are making this country a science and
technology superpower
[Applause]
and madam deputy speaker
as well as investing in infrastructure
and innovation
there is one further part of our plan
for growth that is crucial
providing a world-class education to all
our people
higher skills lead to higher regional
productivity and higher productivity
leads to higher wages
with 80 percent of the uk's 2030
workforce already in work our future
success depends not just on the
schooling we give our children
but the lifelong learning we offer to
adults
we've already done a lot
our plan for jobs invested in
apprenticeships traineeships and the
kickstart scheme but we need to go
further
today's budget invests in the most
wide-ranging skills agenda this country
has seen in decades
we are increasing skill spending
over the parliament by 3.8 billion
pounds an increase of 42
we're expanding t levels building
institutes of technology
rolling out the prime minister's
lifetime skills guarantee upgrading our
fe college estate quadrupling the number
of places on skills boot camps and
significantly increasing funding for
apprenticeships
we are also going to tackle a tragic
fact
millions of adults in our country have
numeracy skills lower than those
expected of a nine-year-old
according to the leading charity
national numeracy this costs individuals
with poor numeracy up to 1600 pounds a
year in lost earnings
people with poor numeracy skills are
more than twice as likely to be
unemployed as their peers so today i can
announce a new uk wide numeracy program
multiply
with 560 million pounds multiply will
improve basic math skills and help to
change people's lives across the whole
united kingdom
so madam deputy speaker
we're building our infrastructure with
new roads railways and broadband
cementing our status as a science and
technology superpower and strengthening
the skills of our people
the country's greatest asset that is a
real plan for growth and that's how this
government is building a stronger
economy for the british people
madam deputy speaker world-class public
services are the people's priority
investment in infrastructure innovation
and skills will create the growth that
we need to pay for them
but as conservatives
we know that government action alone
won't be enough to create a stronger
economy
we want this country to be the most
exciting and dynamic place in the world
for business
and now that we've left the eu we have
the freedom to do things differently
and deliver a simpler fairer tax system
i want to begin with one of our smallest
taxes
but a tax which plays an important role
in one of our preeminent industries
shipping
now that we've left the eu today
we start reforming our tonnage tax
regime to make it simpler and more
competitive
and we're also making it fairer for uk
taxpayers
when we were in the old eu system ships
in the tonnage tax regime required to
fly the flag of an eu state
but that doesn't make sense for an
independent nation so i can announce
today that our tonnage tax will for the
first time ever reward companies for
adopting the uk merchant shipping flag
the red
that ensign is entirely fitting for a
country with such a proud maritime
history as ours
and
madam deputy speaker i am sure i am sure
the opposition i'm sure the opposition
will be delighted that red flags are
still flying somewhere in this country
even if they are
even if they are all at sea
let me turn now
let me turn now
let me turn now to air passenger duty
right now
right now people pay more for return
flights with and between the four
nations of the united kingdom than they
do when flying home from abroad
we used to have a return leg exemption
for domestic flights but were required
to remove it in 2001
but today i can announce that flights
between airports in england scotland
wales and northern ireland will from
april 2023 be subject to a new lower
rate of air passenger duty
this will help cut costs to cut the cost
of living with 9 million passengers
seeing their duty cut by half
it will bring people together across the
united kingdom
and because and because they tend to
have a greater proportion of domestic
passengers it is a boost to regional
airports like aberdeen belfast inverness
and southampton
airports are major regional employers
so to help them get through the winter
i'm also extending our support for
english airports for a further six
months
we're also making changes to reduce
carbon emissions from aviation most
emissions come from international
rather than domestic aviation
so we are introducing from april 2023 a
new ultra long-haul band in air
passenger duty covering flights of over
five 5500 miles when an economy rate of
ninety one pounds less than five percent
of passengers will pay more but those
who fly furthers will pay the most
madam deputy speaker
our approach to corporate taxation
strikes a responsible balance between
funding public services and encouraging
the investment we need for a stronger
economy
at the march budget we took the
difficult but necessary decision to
increase the rate of corporation tax to
25
from 2023
still the lowest rate in the g7 and the
fifth lowest rate in the g20
alongside i introduced the new super
deduction the biggest business tax cut
in modern british history
and extended to the end of this year the
annual investment allowance at its
higher level of a million pounds
now is not the time to remove tax breaks
on investment so i can confirm today
that the one million pound annual
investment allowance will not end in
december as planned it will be extended
all the way to march 2023
also said in march that i would review
the bank surcharge within corporation
tax to maintain the competitiveness of
our financial services industry
we will retain a surcharge of three
percent the overall rate for corporation
tax on banks will in 2023 increase from
27
to 28
and will remain higher than the rate
paid by other companies
small challenger banks are improving
banking competition which is good for
the sector and good for consumers
so to help them i will also raise the
annual allowance to 100 million pounds
madam deputy speaker our manifesto
promised to review business rates we're
publishing our conclusions today
but before i set out our plans let me
say this
we on this side of the house are clear
that reckless unfunded promises to
abolish attacks which raises 25 billion
pounds every year are completely
irresponsible
it would be wrong to find 25 billion
pounds a year in extra borrowing cuts to
public services or tax rises elsewhere
so we will retain business rates but
with key reforms to ease the burden and
create stronger high streets
first
we will make the business rate system
fairer and timelier with more frequent
revaluations every three years the new
revaluation cycle will be delivered from
2023.
second as called for by the federation
of small business and the british
property federation
we're introducing a new investment
relief to encourage businesses to adopt
green technologies like solar panels and
i'm announcing today that we'll accept
the cbi and the british retail
consortium's recommendation to introduce
a new business rates improvement relief
from 2023 every single business will be
able to make property improvements and
for 12 months pay no extra business
rates
that means a hotel adding extra rooms a
manufacturer expanding their factory an
office adding new air conditioning cctv
or bike shelters will all pay no extra
rates
together with the new green investment
relief we're introducing investment
incentives totaling
750 million pounds
this will make a difference but without
action millions of businesses would see
their tax bills going up next year
because of inflation
i want to help those businesses right
now
so our third step
is that next year's planned increase in
the multiplier will be cancelled
that's a tax cut for businesses worth
over the next five years 4.6 billion
pounds
and i have one final measure to help
those businesses hardest hit by the
pandemic
i'm announcing today for one year a new
50
business rates discount for businesses
in the retail hospitality and leisure
sectors
pubs music venues cinemas restaurants
hotels theaters and gyms any eligible
business can claim a discount on their
bills of 50 percent up to a maximum of
110 000 pounds
that is a business tax cut worth almost
1.7 billion pounds
together with small business rate relief
this means that over 90 percent of all
retail hospitality and leisure
businesses will see a discount of at
least 50 percent
apart from the covid release
this is the biggest single year
tax cut to business rates in over 30
years
madam deputy speaker taken together
today's budget cuts business rates by 7
billion pounds
madam deputy speaker we are unleashing
the dynamism and creativity of british
businesses with a simpler fairer and
more competitive tax system the biggest
business tax cut in modern british
history the biggest single year tax cut
to business rates for 30 years a million
pound investment allowance tonnage tax
reformed air passenger duty cut that is
the way to back business and build a
stronger economy
[Music]
madam deputy speaker
let me turn now to alcohol duties
[Music]
first introduced
in 1643
to help pay for the civil war
our alcohol duty system is outdated
complex and full of historical anomalies
the institute of fiscal studies have
called it in their words a mess
the institute of economic affairs said
it defies common sense
and the world health organization have
warned that countries like the eu uk
which follow the eu rules are and i
quote
unable to implement tax systems that are
optimal from the perspective of public
health
so madam deputy speaker today
we are taking advantage of leaving the
eu to announce the most radical
simplification of alcohol duties for
over 140
years we are taking five steps today to
create a system that is simpler
fairer and healthier yeah
first
to radically simplify the system we are
slashing the number of main duty rates
from 15 to just six
our new system will be designed around a
common sense principle
the stronger the drink
the higher the rate
this means that some drinks like
stronger red wines fortified wines or
high strength white ciders will see a
small increase in their rates because
they are currently under taxed given
their strength
that's the right thing to do and it will
help end the era of cheap high-strength
drinks which can harm public health and
enable problem drinking
and because this is a more rational
system
the converse is also true many lower
alcohol drinks are currently over taxed
and have been for many decades
rose
fruit ciders liqueurs lower strength
beers and wines today's changes mean
that they will pay
less
the second step i'm taking today
will encourage small innovative craft
producers
i'm announcing proposals for a new small
producer relief this will extend the
principle of small brewers relief to
include for the first time ever
small cider makers and other producers
making alcoholic drinks of less than
eight and a half percent
third
i'm going to modernize the system to
reflect the way that people drink today
over the last decade consumption of
sparkling wines like prosecco has
doubled english sparkling wine has
increased almost
[Applause]
it's clear they are no longer the
preserve of wealthy elites
and they are no stronger than still
wines
so i'm going to end the irrational duty
premium of 28 that they currently pay
sparkling wines wherever they are
produced will now pay the same duty as
still wines of equivalent strength
and because growing conditions
in the uk
typically favor lower strength and
sparkling wines this means english and
welsh wines compared with stronger
imported wines will now pay
less
sales of fruit cider
have increased from one in a thousand
siders sold in 2005 to one in four today
but they can pay two or three times as
much duty a cider that is made with
apples or pears
so we are cutting the duty on them too
the fourth step i'm taking today
will directly support the home of
british community life for centuries our
pubs
even before the pandemic pubs were
struggling between 2000 and 2019
consumption in the entree fell by 40
and many public health bodies recognize
that pubs are often safer drinking
environments than being at home
so
as the members for dudley south and
northwest durham will agree
a fairer healthier system supports pubs
so i can announce today
draft relief
[Music]
draft relief will apply a new lower rate
of duty on draft beer and cider
it will apply to drink serve from draft
containers over 40 liters it will
particularly benefit community pubs who
do 75 of their trade on draft and let me
tell the house the new rate draft relief
will cut duty by five percent
that is the biggest cut to cider duty
since 1923
the biggest cut to future fruit ciders
in a generation the biggest cut to beer
duty for 50 years
this is not temporary it's a long-term
investment in british pubs of a hundred
million pounds a year and a permanent
cost
a permanent cut in the cost of a pint of
3p
and i cannot wait madam deputy speaker
for the opposition to accuse me tomorrow
of beer barrel politics
[Music]
madam deputy speaker madam deputy
speaker
these much needed reforms
will come into effect in february 2023
but i want to help the hospitality
industry right now
so for my final announcement on alcohol
duties today
i can confirm that the planned increase
in duty
on spirits like scotch whiskey
wine cider and beer will all from
midnight tonight be
cancelled
[Applause]
that's a tax cut worth three billion
pounds
madam deputy speaker our reforms make
the alcohol duty system simpler fairer
and healthier
they help with the cost of living while
tackling problem drinking they support
innovative entrepreneurs and craft
producers they back pubs and public
health
and they are only possible because we've
left the european union
[Music]
[Applause]
madam deputy speaker
world-class public services investment
in infrastructure innovation and skills
simpler fairer taxes to support
businesses and consumers all built on
the foundation of a stronger economy and
responsible public finances that is our
vision for the future and that is what
this budget delivers
and this budget also supports working
families
madam deputy speaker with fuel prices at
the highest level in eight years i'm not
prepared to add to the squeeze on
families and small businesses so i can
confirm today the planned rise in fuel
duty will be cancelled
that's a saving over the next five years
of almost eight billion pounds compared
to pre-2010 plans today's freeze means
the average tank of fuel will cost
around 15 pounds less per car 30 pounds
less for vans 130 pounds less for hevs
after 12 consecutive years of frozen
rates the average car driver will now
save a total of 1
900 pounds
[Music]
madam deputy speaker
i can also announce today that public
sector workers will see fair and
affordable pay rises across the whole
spending review period
as we return to the normal independent
pay setting process
and i can take action to help the lowest
paid as well
it was a conservative government that
introduced the national living wage in
2016.
a
a conservative government
that according to statistics published
just yesterday has overseen the
proportion of people in low paid work
falling to its lowest level since 1997
and it is a conservative government that
is increasing the wage floor again today
the independent low pay commission
brings together economists business
groups and trades unions the government
is accepting their recommendation to
increase the national living wage next
year by six point six percent to nine
pounds fifty an hour
for a full-time worker that's a pay rise
worth over a thousand pounds it will
benefit over two million of the lowest
paid workers in the country
it's broadly consistent with previous
increases and keeps us on track
for our target of two-thirds of median
earnings by 2024 and it is a major
commitment to the high-wage high-skill
high productivity economy of the future
madam deputy speaker
as we build this stronger economy
we're doing so at the end
of an extraordinary 18 months
kovid wasn't just a public health
challenge
it wasn't just an economic challenge
it was a moral challenge too
we had to show that we could pull
together as a country and we did
we had to put aside questions of
ideology and orthodoxy to do whatever it
took to care for our people and each
other
and we did
there's a different kind of moral
dimension to the economic challenge we
face now
last year
the state grew to be over half the size
of the total economy
taxes are rising to their highest level
as a percentage of gdp since the 1950s
i don't like it
but i cannot apologize for it it is the
result of the unprecedented crisis we
faced and the extraordinary action we
took in response
but now
we have a choice
do we want to live in a country where
the response to every question is what
is the government going to do about it
where every time prices rise every time
a company gets in trouble every time
some new challenge emerges the answer is
always the taxpayer must pay
or do we choose to recognize that
government has limits
government should have limits
if this seems
if this seems a controversial statement
to make
then i'm all the more glad for saying it
because that means it needed saying and
it is what we believe
there is a reason we talk about the
importance of family community and
personal responsibility
not because these are an alternative to
the market or the state it's because
they are more important than the market
or the state
the moments that make
life worth living aren't created by
government aren't announced by
government aren't granted by government
they come from us as people
our choices our sacrifices our efforts
and we believe
people should keep more of the rewards
of those efforts
yes
we've taken some corrective action to
fund the nhs and get our debt under
control
but as we look towards the future
i want to say this simple thing to the
house and the british people
my goal is to reduce taxes by the end of
this parliament i want taxes to be going
down not up
i want this to be a society that rewards
energy ingenuity and inventiveness
a society that rewards work
that is what we believe on this side of
the house
that
is my mission over the remainder of this
parliament
and the final announcement in today's
budget takes a first step
madam deputy speaker
for many of the lowest paid in society
there is a hidden tax on work
the universal credit taper withdraw
support as people work more hours
the rate is currently 63
so for every one pound someone earns
their universal credit is reduced by 63p
let us be in no doubt this is a tax on
work
and a high rate of tax at that
organizations
organizations as varied as the trades
union congress the joseph rowntree
foundation the resolution foundation the
center for policy studies and the center
for social justice have all said it is
too high
so
to make sure work pays and helps some of
the lowest income families in our
country keep more of their hard-earned
money
i have decided to cut this rate
not by one percent
not by two percent but by eight percent
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a tax on working people and we
are cutting it from 63 to 55
the re the rate originally envisaged by
my right honourable friend the member
for chingford
and because i'm also increasing the work
allowances by 500 pounds this is a tax
cut next year worth over 2 billion
pounds
nearly two million families will keep on
average an extra thousand pounds a year
changes like this
normally take effect at the start of the
new tax year in april
but we want to help people right now so
we will introduce this within weeks and
no later than december the 1st
[Music]
[Applause]
let me tell the house what these changes
mean a single mother of two renting and
working full time on the national living
wage will be better off by around 1 200
pounds
a couple renting a home with their two
children one working full-time the other
working part-time will be better off
every single year by 1
800 pounds
this is a 2 billion pound tax cut for
the lowest paid workers in our country
it supports working families it helps
with the cost of living and it rewards
work
[Music]
so madam deputy speaker
fuel duty cut air passenger duty cut
alcohol duty cut the biggest cut to
business rates in 30 years growth up
jobs up wages up
public finances back in a better place
more investment in infrastructure
innovation and skills a pay rise for
over 2 million people and a 2 billion
pound tax cut for the lowest paid
this budget helps with the cost of
living this budget levels up to a higher
wage higher skill higher productivity
economy this budget builds a stronger
economy for the british people and i
commend it to the house
[Music]
[Applause]
so no doubt of a warm reception from the
conservative benches uh for what uh
sounded like a tax cutting budget and
which also ended with that uh massive uh
decision uh to uh cut the credit taper
by eight percent uh for those on
universal credit in work
uh now we're going to hear uh in a
moment from rachel reeves the shadow
chancellor who's had to stand in from
sakiya starma the labour leader because
he's tested positive for kovid but
let's just have a quick look at some of
the key measures
from that statement
the chancellor announced that the office
for budget responsibility has upgraded
the growth forecast for 2021 from 4
to 6.5
he also said that there would be a 50
business rate discount for retail
hospitality and leisure he promised that
the overseas aid target will return to
the previous 0.7 of national income by
the end of this parliament 2024-2025
we can go now uh to
the
house of commons where we're going to
hear shortly uh the opposition's
response to the budget one
so we now come
to the motion entitled
income tax charge it is on this motion
that the debate will take place today
and on succeeding days
the questions on this motion and on the
remaining motions will be put at the end
of the budget debate on tuesday 2nd of
november i call the chancellor exchequer
to move the motion formally
sometimes beth budgets are a bit
anti-climactic aren't they but no doubt
that was a fairly major statement
that was a bigger budget than certainly
we were expecting and i would say it was
more a boris johnson budget actually
than a rishi cynic budget and the reason
i say that is for all of the
chancellor's
discussion around fiscal responsibility
and having a smaller
state he actually used some of that
large s from those revised obr
forecasts on the permanent scarring of
covid on the economy it was revised
downwards it gave him billions more to
spend
and there was a lot of spending in that
budget it was a big spending budget he
says he wants to cut taxes at the end of
the parliament but it definitely leans
in to boris johnson's approach to the
conservative party than perhaps
the language that rishi sort of has been
using in recent weeks okay let's go back
to the chamber because we're going to
hear now
from rachel reeves big test for her
responding to the budget
uh standing in for kyrsterman with the
cost of living crisis
businesses hit by a supply chain crisis
those who rely on our schools and our
hospitals and our police
they won't recognize the world that the
chancellor is describing
they will think that he is living in a
parallel universe
the chancellor in this budget
has decided to cut taxes
for banks
so madam deputy speaker at least the
bankers on short haul flights sipping
champagne will be cheering this budget
today
and the arrogance
after taking six billion pounds out of
the pockets of some of the poorest
people in this country
expecting them to cheer today for two
billion pounds given to compensate
in the long story of this parliament
never has a chancellor
asked the british people to pay so much
for so little
time and again today the chancellor
compared the investments that he is
making to the last decade
[Applause]
so let's just reflect on the choices
that chancellor has made today
the highest sustained tax burden in
peacetime
and who is going to pay for it
it's not international giants like
amazon
no the chancellor has found a tax
deduction for them
it's not property speculators they've
already pocketed a stamp duty cut
and it's clearly not the banks even
though banker's bonuses are set to reach
a record high this year
instead the chancellor is loading the
burden on working people
and national insurance tax rise on
working people
a council tax hike on working people
and no support today for working people
with vat on their gas and electricity
bills
and what are working people getting in
return
a record nhs waiting list with no plan
to clear it no way to see a gp and still
having to sell their home to pay for
social care
community policing nowhere to be seen
a court backlog leaving victims without
justice
and almost every rape going unprosecuted
a growing gap
in results and opportunities between
children at private and state schools
soaring number of pupils in super-sized
classes
and no serious plan to catch up on
learning stolen by the virus
two billion pounds announced today a
pale imitation of the 15 billion pound
catch-up fund that the prime minister's
own education czar said was needed no
wonder madame deputy speaker that he
resigned
now the chancellor talks about
world-class public services
tell that to a pensioner waiting for a
hip operation
tell that to a young woman waiting to go
to court to get justice
tell that to a mum and dad waiting for
their child to get the mental health
support that they need
and the chancellor says today that he's
realized what a difference early years
spending
i would just say to the chancellor
has he ever heard of the short start
program that this toronto government
you voted for oh and why are we in this
position why are british businesses
being stifled by debt
while amazon amazon gets tax deductions
why are working people being asked to
pay more tax and put up with worse
services
why is billions of pounds in taxpayers
money being funneled to friends and
donors of the conservative party while
millions of families are having 20
pounds a week taken off of them
madame deputy speaker
why can't britain do better than this
now the government
will always blame others
it's businesses fought
it's the eu's fault
it's the public's fault
the global problems
the same old excuses
but the blunt reality is this
working people are being asked to pay
more for less
for three simple reasons
economic mismanagement
an unfair tax system
and wasteful
spending each of these problems
is down to 11 years of conservative
failure
and they they shake their heads
but the cuts to our public services have
cut them to the bone
and while the chancellor and prime
minister like to pretend that they are
different
this budget today will only make things
worse
the solution starts with growth
the government is caught in a bind of
its own making
because low growth inexorably leads to
less money for our public services
unless taxes rise
and under the conservatives britain has
become a low growth economy
let's look at the last decade
the tories have grown the economy at
just 1.8 a year
if we had grown at the same rate of
other advanced economies we could have
had an additional 30 billion pounds to
invest in public services without
raising the taxes that the tories are
raising on working people today
and let's compare growth under the last
11 years of conservative government to
the last labour government even taking
into account the global financial crisis
labor grew the economy much faster by
2.3 percent a year
if the tories matched that record we
would have 30 billion pounds more a year
to spend on public services
it could not be clearer the
conservatives are now the party of high
taxation because the conservatives are
the party of low growth
and the office for budget responsibility
confirmed this today
that we will be back to anemic growth
they might not like this but the office
of budget responsibility said that by
the end of this parliament the uk
economy will be growing by just 1.3
percent
which is hardly the plan for growth that
the chancellor boasted about today
hardly a ringing endorsement of his
announcements
under the tory decade we have had low
growth and there's not much growth to
look forward to
now the economy has been weakened
by the pandemic but also by the
government's mishandling of it
responding to the virus has been a huge
challenge
governments around the world have taken
on more debt
but our situation is worse than in other
countries
worse because our economy was already
fragile going into the crisis
too much inequality
too much insecure work
too little resilience in our public
services
and worse because the prime minister
didn't delayed against scientific advice
egged on by the chancellor we ended up
facing harsher and longer restrictions
than other countries
so as well as having the highest death
toll
so as well as having the highest death
toll in europe written suffered
order order order order order we've got
to be able to hear the odd war lady
rachel reeves
so as well as having the highest death
toll in europe britain has suffered the
worst economic hit of any major economy
now the chancellor now boasts that we
are growing faster than others
but that's because we fell the furthest
and what the us and others
have already seen their economy bounce
back to level seen before the pandemic
the uk hasn't
our economy is set to be permanently
weaker
on top of all that
the government is now lurching from
crisis to crisis
people avoiding journeys because they
can't fill up their petrol tank is not
good for the economy
people spending less because the cost of
the weekly shop has exploded
is not good for the economy
and british exporters facing more
barriers than their european competitors
because of the deal that this government
did is not good for our economy
if this were a plan
it would be economic sabotage
and when the prime minister isn't
blagging that this chaos is part of his
cunning plan he says that he's not
worried about inflation
we'll tell that to families struggling
with rising gas and electricity bills
with rising prices of petrol at the pump
and with rising food prices
he's out of touch he's out of ideas and
he's left working people out of pocket
madam deputy speaker conservative
mismanagement has made the fiscal
situation tight
and when times are tight it's even more
important to ensure
that taxes are fair that taxpayers get
value for money
but this government fails on both fronts
we have a grossly unfair tax system with
a burden being heaped on working people
successive budgets now have raised
council tax have raised income tax
and now they have raised national
insurance too
but taxes on those with the broadest
shoulders
those who earn their income from stocks
and shares and dividends and property
portfolios
they've been left barely
untouched businesses based on the high
streets are the lifebloods of our
communities
and often the first venture for
entrepreneurs
but despite what the chancellor said
today
businesses will still be held back by
punitive and unfair business rates
the government has failed to tax the
online giants and watered down global
efforts to create a level playing field
and just when we needed every penny of
public money to make a difference
we have a government
that is a byword for waste
cronyism
and vanity projects
we've had 37 billion pounds for a test
and trace system that the spending
watchdog says treats taxpayers like an
atm cash machine
a yacht for ministers
a fancy paint job for the prime
minister's plane
and a tv studio for conservative party
group broadcasts which seems to have
morphed into the world's most expensive
home cinema
three and a half billion pounds of
government contracts awarded to friends
and donors of the conservative party
190 million pound loan to a company
employing the prime minister's former
chief of staff 30 million pounds to the
former health secretary's pub landlord
and every single one of those checks
signed by the chancellor
and now he comes to ordinary working
people and asks them to pay more
more than they have been ever asked to
pay before
and at the same time
to put up with worse public services
all because of his economic
mismanagement his unfair tax system and
his wasteful spending
now of course there are some welcome
measures in this budget today as there
are in any budget
labor welcomes the increase in the
national minimum wage that the
government needs to go further and
faster
if they have backed labour's position of
an immediate rise to at least 10 pounds
an hour then a full-time worker on the
national minimum wage would be in line
for an extra 1000 pounds a year
ending the punitive public sector pay
freeze is welcome
but we know how much this chancellor
likes his smoke and mirrors
so we'll be checking the books to make
sure that the money is there for a real
terms pay rise
labor also welcomes the government's
decision to reduce the universal credit
taper rate as we have consistently
called for
but the system has got so out of work
that even after this reduction
working people on universal credit
still face a higher marginal tax rate
than the prime minister
and those unable to work through no
fault of their own
still face losing over a thousand pounds
a year
and for families who go out to every
work every day
but don't get government benefits on an
average wage who have to fill up their
car with petrol to get to work
who do that weekly shop
and who
see their gas and electricity prices go
up this budget today does absolutely
nothing for them
we have a cost of living crisis
the government has no coherent plan to
help families cope with rising energy
prices
and whilst we welcome the action taken
today on universal credit millions will
still struggle to pay the bills this
winter
the government has done nothing to help
people with their gas and electricity
bills with that cut in vat receipts as
labour has called for
a cut that is possible because we are
outside the european union and could be
funded by
and could be funded by the extra vat
receipts that have been experienced in
last few months
working people are left out in the cold
while the government hammers them with
tax rises
now national insurance is a regressive
tax on working people it is a tax on
jobs
under the chancellor's plans a landlord
renting out dozens of properties
won't pay a penny more in tax
but their tenants in work
will face tax rises of hundreds of
pounds a year
and he is failing to tackle another huge
issue of the day
adapting to climate change
adapting to climate change presents
opportunities
more jobs
lower bills and cleaner air
but only if we act now and if we act at
scale
according to the office of budget
responsibility
failure to act will mean public sector
debt explodes later to nearly 300 of gdp
the only way to be a prudent and
responsible chancellor is to be a green
chancellor
to invest in the transition to a zero
carbon economy
and give british businesses a head start
in the industries of the future but with
no mention of climate in his conference
speech and the most passing of
references today
we are burdened with a chancellor
unwilling to meet the scale of the
challenges we face
homeowners are left to face the costs of
insulation on their own
industries like steel and hydrogen are
in a global race but without the support
that they need
and the chancellor today
has promoted domestic flights over
high-speed rail in the week before cop
26
and it is because of this chancellor
that in this very week that we try and
persuade other countries to reduce their
emissions
this government can't even confirm that
it will meet his 2035 climate climate
reduction target
madame deputy speaker
everywhere working people look at the
moment they see prices going up and they
see shortages on the shelves
but this budget did nothing to address
their fears
household budgets are being stretched
thinner than ever
but this budget did nothing to deal with
the spiraling cost of living
it is a shocking missed opportunity by a
government that is completely out of
touch
there is an alternative
rather than just tweak the system
labour would scrap business rates and
replace it with something much better by
ensuring online giants pay their fair
share that's what being pro-business
looks like
we wouldn't put up national insurance
for working people we would ensure that
the broadest show those are the broader
shoulders pay their fair share
that's what being on the side of working
people looks like
would end the 1.7 billion subsidy that
the government gives to private schools
and put it straight into our local state
schools
that's what being on the side of working
families looks like
and we'll deliver a climate investment
pledge
28 billion pounds
every year for the rest of this decade
that's giga factories to build batteries
for electric vehicles
that's a thriving hydrogen industry
creating jobs in all parts of our
country
and retrofitting so that we keep homes
warm and get our energy bills down
that's what real action on climate
change looks like
[Applause]
this country deserves better but they'll
never get it under this chancellor
who gives with one hand but takes so
much more with the other
the truth is this
what you get with these two
is a classic con game
it's like one of those pickpocketing
operations that you see in crowded
places
the prime minister is the front man
distracting people with his wild
promises
all the while the chancellor dips his
hand in their pockets it all seems like
fun and games
until you walk away and find that your
purse has been lifted
[Music]
but people are getting warm wise to them
every month they feel the pinch
they're tired of the smoke and mirrors
they're tired of the bluster
of the full storms of the promises of
jam tomorrow
labour would put working people first
but use the power of government and the
skill of business
to ensure that the next generation of
quality jobs are created right here in
britain
we'd tax fairly
spend wisely and after a decade of
fortune growth we'd get the britain's
economy firing on all cylinders
that is what a labour budget would have
done today
[Applause]
[Music]
well big cheers there from the labor
benches uh to that speech from
uh the uh substitute uh answering to
that budget uh rachel reeves the shadow
chancellor who stood in for secure
stamina and certainly a strong uh attack
there on the government uh uh she
pointed out that rishi sunak was
constantly
saying how he'd improved things or taken
them back to what they were like in the
last decade
she said well who was in charge in the
last decade the answer is the
conservatives
she said that the wrong people
were being asked to pay more for less
repeatedly contrasting what she said
were tax cuts for the likes of amazon
against the increases in national
insurance and
things such as vat on rising gas bills
so that really
is
where things stand as far as this budget
is concerned strong support uh from each
of the benches for uh the submissions
made by the chancellor and the shadow
chancellor there
well good afternoon as you've seen the
chancellor has unveiled his budget
promising an economy fit for the new age
of optimism
rishi sunak said economic growth would
recover better than had been previously
forecast after the covert pandemic but
he warned of rising inflation in the
months ahead
let's take a look now at some of the
main measures announced by the
chancellor
there was good news for the hospitality
industry a planned increase of alcohol
duty has been cancelled along with a 5
duty cut on draft beer and cider
the planned increase in fuel duty has
also been cancelled and flights between
airports in the united kingdom between
england scotland wales and northern
ireland will be subject to a new lower
rate of air passenger duty uh from april
next year
the chancellor said there would be a 50
business rates discount
for a year for retail hospitality and
leisure he promised that the overseas
aid target would return to the previous
0.7 of national income by the end of
this parliament 2024-25
and he announced 5 billion pounds
towards the removal of dangerous
cladding on buildings
there was confirmation of some of the
big announcements which had been made in
the run-up to the budget the end of the
year-long pay freeze for public sector
workers a rise in the national minimum
wage to nine pounds and fifty pence from
april up more than six percent for those
aged over 23 and a further 5.9 billion
pounds in capital funding to help the
national health service clear the
backlog created by kovid 19.
madam deputy speaker
fuel duty cut air passenger duty cut
alcohol duty cut the biggest cut to
business rates in 30 years growth up
jobs up wages up
public finances back in a better place
more investment in infrastructure
innovation and skills a pay rise for
over 2 million people and a 2 billion
pound tax cut for the lowest paid
this budget helps with the cost of
living this budget levels up to a higher
wage higher skill higher productivity
economy this budget builds a stronger
economy for the british people and i
commend it to the house
well the leader of the opposition labour
leader shakira starmer was absent from
the commons because he tested positive
for kovi just minutes before prime
minister's questions in his place the
shadow chancellor rachel reeves told mps
that the budget was asking working
people to pay less for more and she
accused the chancellor of living in a
parallel universe
never has a chancellor
asked the british people to pay so much
for so little
time and again today the chancellor
compared the investments that he is
making to the last decade
but who was in charge
charged in the slots they paid
they
were so let's just reflect on the
choices that chancellor has made today
the highest sustained tax burden in
peacetime
and who is going to pay for it
it's not international giants like
amazon no the chancellor has found a tax
deduction for them
it's not property speculators
they've already pocketed a stamp duty
cut
and it's clearly not the banks even
though banker's bonuses are set to reach
a record high this year
instead the chancellor is loading the
burden on working people
well here with me in westminster
covering the budget is our political
editor beth rigby and beth um
some truth in rachel reed's repeated
claim that what the chancellor was doing
in some ways was taking the pattern of
spending back to what it was in the last
labour government in 2010
yeah that is true but but let's just i
mean let's have a quick look at the
macro economics i know ed will talk more
about and then how that drills down i
mean what you had there was the economy
is recovering faster than expected the
long term economic scarring from the
covered pandemic is
less severe than the office of budget
responsibility thought just a few months
ago so the economy will be two percent
smaller by the middle of the decade not
three percent smaller that does give the
chancellor you know 20 to 30 billion
more in money to uh pay for that all now
when you get to the policy of this all
there has been talked about this tension
between rishi sunaka has wanted to be
fiscally conservative low tax
careful on spending and then the big
spender boris johnson i think that
budget showed who'd won out and it was
certainly i think framed as a boris
johnson budget that's how i sort i think
that's how economists and observers will
see it but yeah if you go back to what
you just said about labour governments
this is what paul johnson from the
institute of fiscal studies said he said
the 150 billion increase in departmental
spending over the parliament that's a
3.8
real increase he said these are big
spending increases much more in common
with brown and blair than osborne and
cameron so if you wanted uh confirmation
uh that boris johnson is taking blair's
clothes and look no further than this
budget he signaled his intent to
remember when he announced uh the big
the big tax uh increase on national
insurance he said we are the party of
the nhs when he did that now
so there's big spending bigger spending
than we expected we'd expected that the
chancellor would put more away perhaps
for a rainy day because he himself said
that inflation is a concern it could run
up to four percent what if there's
another spike in covered cases um
but is it too good to be true almost and
i think that's where
rachel reeves came in there because from
a labour's perspective
what they're arguing is is when you look
into the figures and we're just looking
through them now
there's lots of tax increases here for
people uh vat is going to go up 4
billion and then 9.3 billion uh in per
year for the next two years council tax
if you look at the office for budget
responsibility it's going to go up to
12.1 billion up 33 from now uh by 2026
7. so i think when we drill into the
numbers rishi sunnah talks a lot about
the big giveaways and a lot about the
spending and a lot about cuts around
alcohol gt fuel duty
but in it are there more tax rises for
people because i think the acid test of
this budget isn't the optics in the
chamber but in five six months time are
people struggling with inflation really
feeling the squeeze of the cost of
living or are their lives improving
under this and have we managed to work
out that key figure whether more is
being taken than is being spent or the
other way around
in terms of the tax take yeah well it
looks like that there's a there's a i
don't know yet actually i haven't worked
that out yet i haven't looked through
the red book but when you look into the
figures this is what i was making the
point on in terms of uh council tax on
vat there will be
much more hidden tax take than perhaps
was presented by the chancellor there
and politically boris johnson there
wearing his cop 26 blue planet badge
but labor
making a great deal both the prime
minister's questions and in their reply
to the budget over uh what's been done
on climate change issues well exactly in
that budget i mean uh the the prime
minister announced a cut in fuel duty
and he announced uh a freezing of uh
fuel sorry airport
uh passenger a freezing of fuel jewels
it hardly speaks to a greener agenda so
there's a lot of talk about being
greener but then in some of the
policy decisions being taken it's not
reflected in actually
the black and white ink of the treasury
well let's uh get more analysis now of
uh the hard facts and figures from our
economic and data editor ed conway ed
thanks adam ashley you asking a moment
ago about that question about what is
that you know is this a giveaway is it
taking money away so we've got these
numbers you know there's a lot of
figures here we're looking through at
the moment but take everything as a
whole and that includes obviously what
we had with the national insurance
decision earlier on this year includes
all of that money about health that
includes things like the triple lock so
changing it from a triple lock to a
double lock that actually kind of
technically brings in a lot of money may
not be new today but it goes in the
numbers we've got today when you put it
all together it does look like it
represents money leaving the treasury so
a giveaway
but as for just you know when we adjust
for things we will get you that data
over the course of the next few hours
and let me just show you what we have
for the time being and put one ipad down
and pick up one other
because i want to show you growth and i
want to show you what happened to
borrowing as well we got new growth
numbers from the office of budget
responsibility this is the big picture
really this is you know how well is the
economy doing and whether these bars are
kind of above the line or below the line
and that shows the economy is growing
nothing above the line that shows the
economy is shrinking and obviously
you'll see that's what happened during
the pandemic an enormous fall these are
the last figures i should say so the
last time the obr looked at these
numbers earlier on this year this is how
these bars look well let me update them
with the latest numbers we just had
through uh today and you can see there
is a change isn't there just look this
year i was saying earlier we need to
have a look at this particular year so
2021 and what happened to this bar did
it go up and yes it has gone up from
four percent to six point five percent
so a very big upgrade there that is a
big
upgrade and one of the strongest years
that we've seen for economic growth
basically in the last few decades
however then you've got a bit of a cut
in the 2022 basically the balances has a
different profile doesn't it when you're
looking at what's happening to the
economy it's called a slightly different
profile slightly stronger this year
slightly weaker the next year and then
have a look through here we go down go
into the future so we're moving through
to 25 26
and here's the other thing that's
striking okay these numbers
1.6
that is not really punchy long-term
economic growth we're talking about you
know below what used to be considered
trend growth about two and a half
percent so is that a bit of a
disappointment perhaps economists will
look at that and say well if you're
hoping for a big productivity busting
budget putting money into leveling up
and hoping for you know an improvement
in our long-term growth potential that's
not all that encouraging at 1.6 percent
that's the official forecast from the
obr just through just now and let's have
a look to borrowing so obviously if
you've got stronger growth that means
potentially more tax revenues coming in
and the economy doing a little bit
better as a result and
certainly the public finances really
needed something like that this shows
you borrowing last time around so again
the forecast from the obr last time
around very big borrowing during the
pandemic obviously this is the year uh
that we're in at the moment let's see
how those have changed can we add the
new figures on so these are the latest
triggers from the obr which have cut the
borrowing forecast in this year in the
next year in the year after that in the
year after that all the way through
over into the end of the forecast
horizon where you're talking about
really quite low levels of boring 46
billion 46 billion 44 billion that's
that's really small by the comparisons
of recent years you know by both the
pandemic and the post-financial crisis
years uh and obviously comes back to
that point that richly soon i wanted to
make that it is about fiscal
responsibility you know you don't have
massive giveaways uh towards the end of
the forecast horizon raising a question
you know and this is a political
question which both of you will be more
qualified to talk about than i will but
at this point does the chancellor then
have more leeway even within his
self-imposed fiscal rules to start doing
tax cuts or indeed giveaways before a
potential election in either of those
two years it looks like but you know
this is a budget which could gear you up
for some giveaways uh in the future
because it wasn't enormous when it comes
to those giveaways that's what we've got
for the time being adam we'll bring you
more of this data including that kind of
breakdown of where the money is being
spent how much of it is going into
people's pockets how much of it is
coming in uh over the course of the next
few hours
thank you very much indeed ed conway
well the chancellor uh repeatedly said
that uh this was a good budget for
business let's get some reaction now
from that world of business
uh
over to our business correspondent helen
ann smith who joins us from swindon
hello man
yes that's right adam i think there was
really a sense from the chancellor that
he would have wanted businesses to come
away from today with a sense that there
was something for them to help them
through the winter as it comes remember
the context a really tough time for
businesses hikes
in national insurance hikes and
corporation tax are raising that
national minimum wage all at the time
where they're dealing with inflation
supply chain problems the labor crisis a
difficult time for business i think a
real sense he wanted to
show some support and that support
certainly came particularly most notably
with a 50 cut
in business rates uh just for this year
up to a cap of 110 000 pounds that will
make a big difference to particularly to
high street businesses to retail
businesses uh who have had a difficult
time for sure and i'm in one of them now
i'm in swindon uh town centre in
something different gift shop i'm joined
by one of the co-owners
ross thank you so much for being with us
so firstly before this was uh the
statement was given you said that
business rates was something you would
really like to see what's your response
today i'm really happy with that really
positive um that has been a sticking
point for us for a long time especially
compared to say the the estimated rental
value of our unit is actually quite high
um i've launched into maintained that
the thing that got us through the
lockdowns and multiple lockdowns last
year was actually cash flow so even
though this is a temporary uh
measure to get us through i'm actually
really happy to see it because it just
means we can recapitalize reinvest and
just keep the wheels turned until we
actually get through to uh brighter
futures because i guess things are still
tough for small businesses like yours
aren't they i know the pandemic was a
particularly difficult time
uh football has recovered to a degree
but things still on slightly shaky form
is that fair to say yeah wobbly um
probably mostly supply chain at the
moment football is feeling quite good at
the moment i definitely think we've had
quite a considerable bounce back
especially in swindon from the lockdowns
to now seeing lots of people lots of old
faces on you which is great
i am struggling to get stuck
from europe from the uk from everyone
even our suppliers who manufacture in
the uk are struggling to get their raw
materials from europe so there are times
when the supply chain for us just kind
of grounds to a halt and we all we can
do is sit here and wait really um i
i'm currently holding more stock than
i've ever held before just on the off
chance i can't get anything and is that
potentially or pushing through to you
having to put your prices up for your
customers
we really don't like doing that and i
don't want to we've been able to sit on
the same prices for a long long time
really good supplier relations and and
various other little bits of you know
movements behind the scenes for us um i
think the inevitability is in the new
year we're going to have to visit some
prices that haven't changed for a long
time there's only so many price changes
we can support swallow from our
suppliers before we have to react
not this side of christmas though thank
you ross really appreciate your time
today worth saying as well there was uh
cuts to alcohol duty for some uh draft
beers and other things as well another
nod i think from the treasury to those
industries that were hardest hit by the
pandemic and could potentially also be
hard hit again if as we head into winter
uh covert rears its ugly head again and
there needs to be more restrictions a
sense particularly for leisure retail
hospitality that the chancellor wanted
to give them something to be optimistic
about today
thank you very much indeed hello none
uh welcome back to the peace hall in
halifax west yorkshire the chancellor
laying out his budget within the last
hour talking about an age of optimism
post covet however labour have accused
rishi sunak of living in a parallel
universe in the face of rising cost of
living demands
well with me now is our political
correspondent kate mccann and kate it
was wide-ranging it was high spending it
was bigger in every way than we expected
and we were just talking there a few
minutes ago and i said do you think
you'll be able to sum it up for a couple
of minutes for us and you said you'd
have panic in your eyes if i asked you
that i'm going to set you the challenge
there was so much in it wasn't there
what were your takeaways yeah it's one
of those where the more information you
take on the harder it is to really try
and work out what's actually happened
we're starting to get some reaction from
business so cbi says although this won't
transform the economy necessarily like
the chancellor says he hopes it will
they do broadly welcome it and you're
right it was bigger than we expected
departmental spending for example that's
gone up to incredibly high levels now
the treasury the chancellor saying 3.8
percent increase the ifs is saying in
their snap analysis actually it's three
percent but regardless of which one it
is it is a huge increase in departmental
spending and we saw lots of smaller
things two billion pound more for school
catch up 3.8 billion pounds for prisons
4.8 billion for councils on social care
so the money is being spent lots of it
is capital investment and clearly rishi
sunak also very focused on making sure
that he sticks to those fiscal rules
which ultimately will allow him to get
back to 0.7 spending on age for example
but not until 2024. so it was very much
a budget all about balance but i think
there will be some questions the
universal credit uplift we were talking
about it before we actually heard from
rishi sunak and we were talking about
how it might go from 63 pence to 60
pence well he shocked everybody
including one of your guests who was
before saying 55 would be what they
would want to see it is 55 pence so that
is more than we thought the chancellor
was going to do it will make a
difference to some working families but
important to say not everybody around 2
million who are working who are on the
work allowance that's not everyone on
your universal credit it won't
compensate for that 20 pounder lift up
20 pound a week uplift which has been
removed for everyone so labor saying it
doesn't go far enough but i think the
signals broadly and it is very very
early days is that this is a chancellor
who is keen to steal some of that ground
from labour more than we've even seen
the party do already to invest in public
services to hope that skills investment
will increase productivity and overall
help the country ride out that potential
for inflation rising important to say
the forecast on inflation
done before the increase in energy
prices said four percent that could
potentially go as high as five percent
now that would put a real squeeze on
what the chancellor has announced today
so it's important to wait for a couple
of months to see how all this settles
but certainly a welcome from lots of
people big questions though where was
the green stuff where was where was all
the stuff about investment in green
technology yes there's a lot of research
and development investment although
again delayed by two years businesses
will be disappointed to hear that but
you know cutting apd passenger duty yes
it's great for domestic flights but at
the end of the day that coupled with the
fuel duty freeze means that there will
be people saying we're going into cop
looking like we're not doing as much as
we possibly could have been doing on the
green investment so there are some
questions i think for the chancellor but
we are still digesting it all as you say
yeah in the coming hours and days keep
it sky news through the analysis of the
budget as we go through all those facts
and figures delivered by the chancellor
to find out the truth of what's been
announced this afternoon kate thank you
i'm going to come back to you in a
minute because i want to talk about the
pre-budget drama yeah involving labour
as the kirstarma testing positive uh
we'll talk about that in just a moment
but we're going to go live to central
lobby now inside the houses of
parliament and our deputy political
editor sam coats hi sam
hello good afternoon so what a budget
that was much bigger than many
anticipated spending on public services
up spending on welfare up it looked to
many as if it was as kate was just
saying a raid into labor terrain so what
does labour make of it i'm joined by
peter kyle now he's the mp for hov he's
also labor's schools shadow schools
minister and he joins me
now peter some would say that the tories
in a funny way on the benches in the
commons just there uh in the chamber
were a bit more muted than normal
but that's because a lot of the policies
that the chancellor's just announced
were would be more would appeal more to
your voters wouldn't it in the previous
uh budgets i sat in when it was phil
hammond and when it was george osborne
you couldn't hear yourself thinking
there because the tories are cheering so
loudly here it was muted but not muted
because they didn't like some of the
policies that were announced it was
muted because the overall budget didn't
match the scale of the challenge our the
british economy uh faces at the moment
just look at the one glaring
fact that's emerged just in the last
hour that's that inflation stands at
four percent but growth is going to be
about 1.3 percent there is a huge chasm
between what people are going to be
earning and the mon and the money and
the value of the money that people can
spend none of the measures individually
will tackle that either for businesses
and particularly for people who are in
work and on low incomes at the moment so
i suppose the question is first of all
in that budget which did have a raft of
measures many of which would be i
suspect supported by uh people like you
because they're spending on things that
you think uh
are needed what do you oppose what
measure would you vote against that
rishi sunak has just announced there are
certain measures in there that i would
but they're very limited and very
specific and very targeted the problem
that we've got at the moment is he's not
repurposing the economy for the 2020s
so i'm going to i want to stop you i
want to ask which would you oppose and
therefore which would you let go through
what i'm saying is that at the moment
this is a budget that reflects the
priorities of tory party donors and
where their wealth come from comes from
it does not reflect the where the where
the wealth of the general economy comes
from that's the problem we are taxing
more and more and more people who are on
high street small businesses who are
trading face-to-face with people we're
taxing less and less those businesses
have shifted online that means where our
economy is susceptible to people global
companies that are coming in and making
a lot of money out of our economy and
it's punishing those who are hard
working up and down our country in high
streets so in a budget which saw rishi
sunak
play to labour voters the question for
labour will be what do you oppose i
think we're going to be waiting for an
answer for a while
[Music]
uh sam coats in the lobby thank you very
much plenty of reaction to what we've
heard from the chancellor throughout the
day here on sky news we're still
digesting the big announcements and the
figures will bring you all the analysis
uh throughout the day a big focus on
levelling up and funding for the whole
of the uk in that speech today rishi
sunak announcing what he called the
largest block grants for devolved
nations since devolution he also
allocated the first round of bids from
the leveling up fund and listed some of
those areas
we are backing projects in aberdeen
berry burnley lewis clued south and not
one not two but three successful
projects for the great city of
stoke-on-trent
[Applause]
but that's but that's not all we're also
going to fund projects in ashton
underline
south leicester
sunderland
doncaster and west leeds
and deputy speaker
we are so committed to leveling up we
are even leveling up the opposition
front bench
[Applause]
uh well let's see what business people
here in west yorkshire making of what
they heard from the chancellor this
afternoon i'm joined now by martin
hathaway managing director of the
mid-yorkshire chamber of commerce and
alongside him nikki chance thompson ceo
and trustee of the peace hall which is
hosting us uh here in halifax today
hello to you both
um
we are still digesting the budget it was
so wide-ranging there was such a lot lot
in it and so there's still a lot more to
come out but let's just talk about what
we know so far
and martin going into this budget what
do you want and early indicators from
what you heard do you think you got any
of it i think we we got some of it we
got a review of the business rate system
undertaken and there's definitely things
there that will help business in
particular smaller businesses but we did
want a more fundamental review i think
it was very interesting to hear what a
positive view that chancellor has of how
businesses are doing at the moment and
and that is true of of halifax
businesses the halifax business has been
very resilient throughout this
um just slightly concerned he doesn't
address all of the the issues that are
coming around the corner the
inflationary pressures that are going to
be caused by the increase of costs of
staff
of transport and of power yeah he talked
about inflation say it could go up to
four percent but since he said that uh
the ifs have come out said actually
could be more like five percent um
nikki martin was just talking there
about businesses in west yorkshire and
how resilient they've been we can see
that today a bit of half term trade here
in the peaceful lots of families about
and going inside all the small
businesses here i may have spent a few
pounds myself half an hour or so ago and
but talk to me about what it's been like
and what these businesses need from the
government over the next three years
because we're still in uncertain times
do you think the chancellor delivered to
provide that optimism he talked about
i think he did i mean the commitment
towards culture and heritage high
streets i think is really positive
the peace hall has helped transform
calderdale over the last four years
since it reopened
generating gva of 26 million so it just
demonstrates what culture and heritage
can do
i think i would have liked to have seen
something around vat being frozen for
longer
although we have traded okay and
reasonably the retail sector is still a
little bit sluggish hospitality has
picked up tremendously because naturally
people have wanted to meet up with each
other see family and friends but i think
that the vat freeze could have helped
alongside the business rate relief
slash to 50 again that's tremendously
helpful and there is recognition that
we're not out of the woods yet there is
optimism and hope here at the peace hall
that we will continue to recover but i
think
my my advice to richard is you know
don't go too fast with taxation we're
still
emerging from the pandemic we're not
quite out of the operating theatre yet
there's still a long way to go yeah vot
of course uh set to go up in april and
let's talk about um the business rates
announcement um he wanted to create a
fairer and timelier uh business rate
system um from 2023 is going to be
reevaluated frequently uh amongst the
announcements he says there's going to
be a 50 discount for business rates for
retail uh hospitality and leisure for a
year and he also talked about an
introduction of new business rate
improvement relief things for things
like hotel improvements if a factory
wants to extend and what did you make of
that i think you should have gone much
further
the the the 50 discount um for the next
year is really welcome and will make a
huge um difference to our high streets
and uh
and our businesses uh everywhere in the
in the sectors that can benefit from it
um but the rate system has been
unsuitable as a as a method of taxing
businesses for a very long time taxing
on property doesn't happen elsewhere uh
and uh we at the the chambers of
commerce have been saying that that
should be reflected elsewhere in the
corporation tax system
however what he has announced will help
it's always been slightly odd that if
you spend money on renovating your
business that you that you rent on the
property that you're in that your rates
bill will go up so your costs go up on
top of that and that's been recognized
and that will be appreciated by
businesses and something that wasn't
mentioned um well it would
it was mentioned slightly is hs2 and
then the vague reference to uh you know
the rail networks across the country and
and and
that's part of leveling up and martin
would you like to hit heard more on that
obviously he's committed a lot of money
to transport but do you feel a bit
fobbed off
yes it was top of my list was to get the
announcement for the the east hand the
east the east side and it may or may not
come later we've been told this a lot so
i would have liked to have seen
announcement about about hs2 and more um
specifics around how we're going to
level up the north and use the transport
system to do that one of the biggest
issues that our members tell us they
have is is is transport across the north
is getting across the north getting from
liverpool and getting to hull
and
until we do something about that system
and get some recognition from it um we
will we're a long way off being able to
be leveled up i'd also like to see more
on what leveling up means i'm not sure i
know
as yet so how yeah nikki are you any
clearer about levelling up for places
like halifax after that
budget i'm not sure i'm clear on what
the plan is but the peaceful is actually
a really good practical example of where
levelling up can work so for a 19
million pound investment with a 26
million pound gva return on investment
the town is transforming you can see
that the impact of that is considerable
but but simply if we want these great
assets to work cultural destinations to
work tourism destinations to work we
need good infrastructure and we need
good transport and at the moment halifax
and mostly north is underserved by
regular and sufficient public transport
so for me it's
you know them really setting out the
plan more clearly so that we understand
what's coming so that we can react to
that and respond to that yeah we did
talk to the mayor for west yorkshire
tracy braven earlier here on sky news
and she was talking about local
transport warning investment the
chancellor did um announce 5 billion
pounds for local roads 5 billion for
buses and cycling networks and 50 local
road upgrades but as you said it's that
bigger investment that you were looking
out for today that the chancellor said
is going to be safe for another day we
didn't even get time to get onto alcohol
tax which is the peace hall it's such a
vibrant center for people to come
and mix it it's a hot topic but we will
talk about that later thank you so much
for joining us really good to see you
and kate mccann our political
correspondent has dubbed it the prosecco
budget i wonder if adam can do any
better uh you're sky news budget live
from westminster
well not just prosecco sarah jane but
also champagne but on the other hand red
wine sherry they're going to be more
expensive now so
it depends what your tipple is really
well coming up you're watching sky news
budget special and we're going to get
more reaction
from the chair